[Music]  as for people affected by those coyotes  and the coyotes we light in our house  and we give the SCOTUS what they deserve  what we do it's a good thing I brought  you something like a water we are  careful of math people  we are actually making the difference in  the world  my friends in the cons he's badly hurt  is anybody else gonna show up nah nah we  need to get him some medicine  what's your name buckle I messed it way  too pretty for a name like that we need  to find him I need to take it of them  there are certain things that what you  getting to you can never get out you're  gonna die if you don't leave right now  this is how you repay me  he's hiding something from you she's  just protecting me don't try to outsmart  me your meals every time  you